pleased to say the deputy prime minister
is with us now mr rob good morning to
you you've been in your constituency at
the weekend
2743 majority how angry are people
look i think there is some frustration
and people feel it's uh
there's an issue of double standards i
have to say i was out canvassing three
times and i i didn't get it raised a lot
with me what people care about is that
the government is focused on their
issues and making their lives better and
the vaccine roll out we're the most
boosted in europe we've got we're the
most tested in europe we've got the most
antivirals in europe in terms of the
vaccine program and as a result we've
come out of lockdown the economy is
growing jobs are up uh wages are up
economic growth is up and it's really
important that we deal with these
allegations and these claims that's what
the sue gray inquiry is for but actually
that allows us to focus on what people
really care about and frankly that's the
overwhelming feedback that i've had and
i think most people across the country
so nobody on the doorstep has brought up
boris johnson's behavior oh it gets
brought up but what do they say well i
think the frustration is is they want to
see the government focusing on their
priorities what do they say about boris
johnson's behavior well you get mixed uh
views but i have to say it didn't get
raised a lot with me when it was what
did they say well i think people want to
know that we're focused they want to
know that there's not double standards
and they want to know that we're focused
on their priorities which is why uh
where we've got to now we're the most
boosted country in europe we're out of
the lockdown measures where the economy
is growing far faster than almost all of
our uh major economic uh uh comparators
and we're talking about the issues that
matter people that's why i'm talking
about crime fighting today
but i think that's the issue so they are
worried about double standards then some
of your constituents look i think ever
since i became an mp in 2010 and you
remember the expenses scandal uh i think
uh of course any perception of double
standards is really serious we
understand that frustration that's
precisely why sue gray will look at all
of these issues through great work
full transparency and accountability
okay have you spoken about the concerns
of your constituents to the prime
minister
well look i i think he's well aware of
the frustration he expressed he
articulated it he apologized for it with
contrition in the house of commons
um if it transpires that he lied to
parliament
should he step down okay
you're gonna say sue grey i know but the
question remains if a prime minister
lies to parliament should they step down
look i'm not going to speculate on
hypothetical questions speculating i'm
and i'm and i'm confident i'm serious
that he's definitely premise is
straightforward with the house of
commons but of course as you fight you
say sue gray will look at all the
various different bits of snippets and
claims and and assertions okay well
let's just clarify what he actually said
to pmq's or to the house via pmq's last
week
when i went into that garden just after
six on the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
dominic cummings says he's lying
well look uh the promise has been very
clear as you heard in the house of
commons uh and uh you know that is the
position and of course sugray will be
able to uh to the name four times
i mean it's a bit of a running joke
about how many times ministers can say
sugar she's the most famous woman in
britain i think if you set up an
investigation to look at something uh
which people are saying and i accept is
as serious as this it's important to
respect the integrity of it so that's
why we refer to it and you said that's
his position but this is what dominic
cummings says is the truth i said to the
pm something like martin's invited the
building to a drinks party this is what
i'm talking about you've got to get a
grip on this mad house
the pm waved it aside he went on to say
not only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath
that this is what happened he says the
prime minister's lying look the pm has
been very clear that's not true or
accurate uh and
he's given telling
if i don't get drawn in to
the soap opera of what uh one or other
claim has been made uh that's not the
position
well no i think it's about whether the
prime minister's lie to the nation and
his colleagues i've been very clear that
i think it's a serious issue which is
why we've got the independent
investigation what i'm not going to do
is pre-emptively by whom get into sucre
yes indeed well
well done but but we're not i'm not
going to get into commenting on every
little snippet that makes it way into
the papers precisely because as you
asked me i think what people want us
really focused on yes that's important
needs to be looked at proper
transparency the things that matter in
their daily lives which is coming out
this pandemic the economic
measures that we've taken to save 15
million jobs through the course of the
pandemic getting ourselves back on the
front foot wages are rising and the
crime fighting agenda which is uh we're
putting forward with doubling the
comeback the magistrates come back to
that meantime this is what's happening
in places like derbyshire at
constituency offices they're adorbing
lies like that written all over uh the
mp's uh front door if you will um so the
message is not getting across about what
you're saying well i don't think you can
judge mainstream opinion this country by
those who would act and take a can of
spray paint and adore graffiti on
someone's office and i don't think
that's responsible behavior okay what
about maria corfield then she's the
health minister she wrote this on her
website it's clear that there was a
culture inside number 10 where even if
rules were not technically broken the
spirit of the rules were and this is
completely unacceptable so if you put
aside what happened in derbyshire this
is what a minister saying well but i
think actually the prime minister's been
very clear that things happen that
shouldn't have done he's apologized for
that and sue gray is looking at all of
the details so we can have a proper
accounting of it yeah okay um
we've also heard from other ministers uh
as well they've underlined uh in more
detail that basically this is death by a
thousand cuts and it's either now or
when sue grey's report comes out
oh sorry what is death by a thousand
cuts and what is now
okay when i'm glad you asked me i'll go
into it in more detail we've just been
hearing um from what dominic cummings
said what we've seen written on the
walls what the prime minister said at
the time um and in detail what the
health minister said as well all of
these things are building up to saying
the prime minister is not trustworthy
loads of frenetic commentary that's why
you have sue gray looking at this so you
can have a proper investigation into the
facts and then full transparency and the
accountability that comes and if she
finds that the prime minister if she
finds that the prime minister misled
parliament what happens then look i'm
not going to speculate uh on
hypothetical scenarios what i am going
to do is recognize the importance and
the public frustration with any
perception and any reality of double
standards and let sue grey do her job
that's the right thing to do okay um
okay so uh hypothetical is is the other
word that comes up a lot with uh sue
gray i suppose we'll know by the end of
next week and then see what happens then
but you were running the country for two
weeks weren't you when the prime
minister was poorly
were you at all aware
of uh a drinking culture no i mean
the thing i would say is that people
working extremely long hours and so it
doesn't surprise me if they were if
people as you see in other walks of life
had a glass of wine or beer at the end
of a very long week but i'll tell you
against the rules i'll tell you
not in a work setting but i'll tell you
something okay because i think it's
important and i can only talk to what i
know and what i see and no one is
incredibly i mean there was a
speculation that the
20th of may party was held uh in my
honor to thank me um it was just
ridiculous no of course not ridiculous
it was a party no exactly no
you refer to it as the tragedy
this is the claim that was made and it
was not what you just said it was
nonsense i wasn't invited
and i didn't attend so what i can tell
and so i don't think anyone is accusing
me of that what i can tell you from what
i saw precisely because i did spend a
sustained period is is number 10
particularly during that period uh when
the pm was unwell uh and uh in hospital
but also throughout the pandemic has
been working phenomenally hard under
grueling conditions and i and i do not
and i do not and i do not personally
from my own experience recognize
the caricature that they were all uh
partying uh that this was incredibly
serious uh and difficult and dedicated
uh team so i'm just telling a dj in the
basement they they've got on will swing
and broke it they took a suitcase so
okay i'm just telling you what i saw and
why my experience yeah but you can't say
that they weren't taking advantage a lot
of the people in downing street given
that you know we've had several
eyewitnesses who illustrated what
happened so again all i'm telling you is
what i saw you asked me for my personal
experience and what i'm telling you is i
think that uh um the the the conditions
in a crucible-like context in a pandemic
that we've the likes of which we've
never seen before all of my exposure
direct and personal was to an incredibly
hard working team
but the pictures that we've seen look i
i feel as frustrated as anyone else um i
think double standards is toxic um i i
get all of that i get the frustration
majesty feels about what was happening
in dining street the day before number
10 number 10 is apology but i wonder
what you think look i think it was right
to apologize for it of course i want to
see comply i'm a lawyer by heart i want
to see the rules uh comply with i also
recognize that
as lawmakers the government has got to
be uh take a lead uh show um it is uh
acting to the highest standards
otherwise how can we expect others to
follow it i get all of it yeah but if i
may a deputy prime minister you're
picking and choosing about what you
believe and what you don't believe you
know some some parties did go ahead the
day before the uh the funeral of the
duke of edinburgh but the one on the
20th of may wasn't a party no the
question so we have to wait for the
questions
yes but but you were asking me what i'd
seen you in fact perfectly fair you say
i spent a lot of time in number 10
during the period where the pm was
unwell and
uh and after um in my capacity's first
secretary and uh and since i didn't find
sex at the time and all i'm telling you
is you've never seen this fridge that
they're talking about no no i was never
saw the fridge i mean in fact and all
i'm saying is in fairness i think
there's something of a caricature that
is being depicted uh against the
incredibly professional dedicated hard
work that i saw and i can only vouch uk
good uh conscience about what i saw
sounds like they're all going to be
thrown under the bus we'll have to wait
and see what happens um with that
whether it's got 350 million quid
written on the side of it or not yes we
will apparently uh tell me about the
courts look we've got this backlog in
the crown courts in particular we've
started to get the backlog down in the
magistrates court since the peak in june
we've got the crown court backlog which
he is the most serious cases and was
affected by the socially dis the social
distancing rules particularly jury
trials that backlog is down by 2000
we've put secured a billion pounds to
get the courts back up and running over
the next three years and get the
the backlog down one of the additional
things we're doing is doubling the
sentencing powers of magistrates from
six months to 12 months and what that
will do is get more cases um going
through the courts we will see uh
criminals brought to brought to book
victims having to wait less time and a
further estimated 1700
of those cases in the backlogged crown
courts reduced so this is i think the
right thing to do and i hope everyone
will support it well except the criminal
bar association who says negligible
impact
well it will have an impact uh on top of
the 2000 that we've reduced the backlog
so the backlog in june at the peak was
around 61 000 it's now down to 59 000.
this will take 1 700 off but i'll tell
you what um we need to work together as
a team the law is incredibly important
they've done a great job through the
pandemic the judiciary and the court
service have but i have to say the
criminal bar association have been
threatening strike action the one thing
that will hold back our recovery from
this pandemic will be an irresponsible i
think
unwarranted
industrial action
by criminal barristers we are out of
time but indulge me if you would with
your expertise when you were foreign
secretary we're being told that we're
days away in ukraine days away from what
i don't we're not sure what you're well
i'm referring to the fact that the
ukraine and russia the russian more than
a hundred thousand troops are on the
russian border we're being told what
days away
i had uh the ukrainian ambassador sat
there just last week and he was
concerned about world war three and
sending people back in body bags well
we're absolutely clear ukraine along
with our partners and allies we support
uh ukraine's territorial integrity its
rights to defend itself and we've been
very clear to moscow
that any invasion would be met with
sanctions and economic and financial
response by the international community
and it's important uh that russia
de-escalates and dials down its rhetoric
and its aggressive behavior
uh you're always honest and open thank
you very much for joining us it's going
to be an interesting week next week
isn't it who is this there's a report
apparently coming out i can't remember
the name yeah exactly it's good to talk
to you as always thank you deputy prime
minister